heute sprechen wir über die wörter hin
und her
viele von euch haben schon danach
gefragt und haben darum gebeten dass wir
einmal den unterschied erklären und das
machen wir heute los gehts hin und her
sind zwei adverbien die eine richtung
anzeigen hin und her können sowohl
alleine stehen als wort aber sie können
auch kombiniert werden das zeigen wir
euch gleich noch hin und her beschreiben
also eine richtung hin beschreibt wenn
ich zu einem ort gehe her beschreibt
wenn ich von einem ort komme hier seht
ihr mal eine kleine demonstration
wo gehe ich hin
ich gehe da hin wo komme ich her
ich komme da ja hin und her benutzt man
also immer dann wenn man über richtungen
spricht und dabei kommt es auch auf die
perspektive an
immer wenn ich darüber spreche dass ich
von meiner jetzigen position zu einer
anderen position gehe dann benutze ich
hin ich gehe dahin aber wenn ich darüber
spreche dass jemand anders zu meiner
position kommt dann benutze ich her
hier ist noch eine weitere szene
hey wo bist du ich bin im park und
beobachte die flügel kommst du auch her
ich komme da nimmt in dieser szene habt
ihr gehört wie ich zu janisch gesagt hab
kommst du her also aus meiner
perspektive
ich war im park und ich wollte gerne
dass er zu mir kommt her heißt also zu
mir
janisch auf der anderen seite hat gesagt
ja ich komme da hin aus seiner
perspektive hat er den ort verlassen und
ist woanders hingegangen und wenn ihr
vielleicht probleme habt diese beiden
wörter zu verwechseln her und hin dann
merkt euch vielleicht eines von den
beiden und wenn ihr euch das eine merkt
könnt ihr euch auch das andere merken
und mein vorschlag wäre dass ihr euch
herr merkt hier ist immer diese bewegung
zu mir und ich möchte euch noch einen
kleinen ausdruck mitgeben den ihr sehr
sehr oft hört auf der straße in
deutschland das ist der ausdruck kommt
wer sind eigentlich drei wörter komm mal
her und man spricht die aber oft so
schnell aus dass sie wie zwei wörter
klinkhammer her sagen vielleicht eltern
zu ihren kindern wenn die weglaufen oder
komm mal her st recht eine gruppe von
jugendlicher wenn jugendliche wenn die
einen wollen dass die anderen auch
rüberkommen
ja das hört man sehr oft achtet mal
darauf wenn ihr in deutschland auf der
straße seit man hört dass ständig komm
mal her
ja das kann man ja mache ich nicht jetzt
kommt maria
übrigens werden ihr sie und sophie auch
zu diesem video wieder einige
interaktive übungen vorbereiten mit
denen ihr dieses thema hin und her noch
weiter üben könnt diese übungen bekommen
alle menschen die uns als mitglied jeden
monat unterstützen und das könnt ihr
auch machen auf katrin dot com / german
ihr habt gerade gesehen das hin und her
eigentlich gar nicht so schwierig sind
aber eine sache die es manchmal ein
bisschen kompliziert macht ist dass man
hin und her sehr oft kombiniert und ganz
oft stehen diese adverbien gar nicht
alleine sondern in kombination mit einem
anderen wort hin und her können alleine
stehen man kann sie aber auch mit
anderen art werben kombinieren und man
kann sie auch mit verben und sogar mit
norman kombinieren und wir werden euch
jetzt mal die wichtigsten oder
vielleicht die bekanntesten davon
vorstellen
fangen wir an mit einem wort das sie
alle kennt wahrscheinlich das ist wohin
im deutschen sagt man nicht wo gehst du
sondern man sagt wohin gehst du und dort
benutzt man also immer dieses hin um die
richtung zu zeigen wohin gehst du
ähnlich ist dahin ich gehe dahin und wir
haben übrigens auch schon mal über diese
ganzen wörter mit da ein video gemacht
dass verlinkt ich mal hier oben diese da
wörter im deutschen denn dieses wo und
dieses da das kann man ziemlich häufig
mit verschiedenen wörtern auch
kombinieren und beide links sind hier
oben und hier unten
das nächste wort ist hinfahren oder so
ähnlich ist hinkommen
ich kann sagen wann fährst du dahin wir
fahren zu meinen eltern wann fährst du
dahin wann kommst du hin hinstellen
ein anderes wort wenn ich etwas nehme
und das von mir weg bewege dann sage ich
ich stelle mein glas dahin zum beispiel
auf den tisch ein typisches nomen mithin
wäre zum beispiel hinfahrt ihr kennt das
wenn ihr ein ticket kauf zum beispiel in
deutschland mit der bahn
dann kann man ein hinfahrt ticket kaufen
und ein rückfahrticket man sagt also
nicht hinfahrt und herfahrt sondern man
sagt hinfahren zum ort hin fahren weil
man zurückkommt ist es ein
rückfahrtticket das nächste wort ist
hinauf wenn ich zum beispiel nach oben
gucken dann schaue ich hinauf in den
himmel ich kombiniere also dieses auf
nach oben mit der richtung hinauf nach
oben hin ein anderes wort was ihr häufig
hört vielleicht ist hinaus ich kann
sagen wenn ich in einem gebäude bin dann
gehe ich hin aus ich gehe also aus dem
gebäude raus man benutzt aus mithin
hinaus und auch ein gutes wort hinhören
ich höre aber ich höre nicht einfach nur
so sondern ich höre in eine bestimmte
richtung
ich höre da hin ich will genauer hören
was da passiert ich höre hin
das waren also einige bekannte wörter
mithin und all diese wörter habt ihr
gesehen
in all diesen wörtern ist die bewegung
so hin ich höre hin ich komme dorthin
ich fahre hin
jetzt zeigen wir euch einige wörter mit
her und die sind immer die
entgegengesetzte richtung
zum beispiel herkommen ich sage so
janisch kommst du her kommst du zu mir
oder auch das wort heraus wenn etwas
heraus geht dann ist das aus der
perspektive von außen
wir hatten eben hinaus es ist meine
perspektive ich bin im haus ich gehe
hinaus wenn ich aber draußen stehe dann
sage ich zu janisch kommst du heraus
auch andere wörter wo man vielleicht
nicht sofort diese asse
die aktion hat haben etwas mit dieser
bewegung her zu tun
herkunft zum beispiel ist ein wort das
man benutzt wenn man darüber spricht
woher jemand kommt was ist deine
herkunft auch herstellen ist eigentlich
ein wort das man nicht direkt verbindet
mit dieser bewegung aber wenn man sich
das überlegt herstellen heißt dass man
etwas neues schafft etwas kreiert und
das passierte quasi aus dem nichts kommt
das zu mir ich stelle zum beispiel einen
tisch her den baulich und dann habe ich
diesen tisch gestellt
ein wort das sie alle kennt ist
herunterladen wenn man etwas aus dem
netz herunter lädt also das deutsche
wort für download dann ist das auch eine
kombination mit herunter also das ist
online irgendwie hin wer klaut und dann
kommt das runter zu mir und diese
richtung ist ja hier runter kann man
natürlich wird nicht verstehen oder
herunterladen
bis dann was man im internet macht und
das letzte wort ist ein ausdruck den ihr
vielleicht auch schon mal gehört hat das
hin und her hin und her benutzt man
immer dann wenn man sich nicht
entscheiden kann und das kann man auch
ganz wörtlich verstehen
eine argumentation oder eine diskussion
geht immer hin und her hin und her und
am ende sagt man auch dieses hin und her
das kann ich jetzt nicht mehr hören noch
ein allerletzter hinweis für alle von
euch die das wort her schon mal in einem
anderen kontext gehört haben
es gibt tatsächlich noch eine zweite
bedeutung von heer und die hat gar
nichts mit einem ort oder eine richtung
zu tun sondern mit der zeit man kann zum
beispiel sagen das ist zehn jahre her
ist es egal also man kann es übersetzen
mit ergo und diese bedeutung hat nichts
mit dem anderen herzen tun aber ich
wollte es trotzdem erwähnt
damit ihr zumindest wisst welche andere
bedeutung ist noch gibt wenn ihr jetzt
noch mehr üben möchte zu diesem thema
dann kommt euch unbedingt mal unsere
interaktiven schied an
damit könnt ihr noch mehr lernen und die
bekommt ihr als mitglied von the german
ein mitglied werdet ihr auf tt.com /
german und wenn ihr noch mehr fragen
habt wenn ihr gerne mal wissen möchte
was bedeutet denn dieser ausdruck oder
was ist der unterschied zwischen diesem
wort und diesem wort dann schreibt uns
einen kommentar und vielleicht
beantworten wir nächstes mal eure frage
danke für zu sehen und bis zum sonntag
kann man ja nicht jetzt komme hier nicht
her
jetzt kommt ja auch quatsch
[Musik]